I got a lot of my inspiration from my
basketball coach at UCLA that my brother
mentioned John Wooden and he developed a
thing called the pyramid of success I
don't know how many of you guys heard of
that about this and it's inspired me a
lot and in my approach to acting and
coach developed it for his English class
before he was even a coach it wasn't for
a basketball team and basically what it
is it's all these blocks of
characteristics that you need to find
success and first coach success had
nothing to do with winning it had to do
with leaving the task knowing that
you've done your very best now the guy
won almost ten straight national
championships no one's ever gonna get
close to that and and the the
cornerstones of the pyramid are in
enthusiasm joy and industriousness hard
work because coach said anybody can come
to the task with hard work in mind but
when you bring a hard work and joy
together then that's when fantastic
things happen and then the very top and
Jeff mentioned the word faith the
pyramid is is cut in two at the apex
faith and patience you know it's when
when it's game time when you've got all
the other things and you built them and
you know teamwork and friendship and
loyalty and all these other blocks and
you get ready for to play the game you
better have faith and you better have
patience and when you're acting there's
so there's the weirdest thing about it
is like the time crunch you know you
were talking about that and you got to
get it done before the Sun gets down
this and that and all the money that's
involved and it gets you can make you
really uptight but you're in there with
somebody else usually your teammate and
you have to have patience you know if it
doesn't come right away you can't get
all squirrely and screwed up because
then it's never gonna happen you just
got to relax
listen work with that teammate
maybe they're gonna throw your pass so
maybe you can score the winning basket
you know you never know